der Kampf ums Auto den Fechten wir heute
Abend aus bei Bild die richtigen Fragen
und wir streiten mit der Berliner Grünen
Antje carpek die stolz ist darüber dass
immer mehr Straßen in Berlin zu
Fahrradstraße werden ja da bin ich stolz
drauf ich glaube das ist wichtig ist und
das zeigen viele andere europäische
Städte also wenn ich den Verkehr
ordentlich sortiere ist eigentlich mehr
eine Frage von deutscher Ingenieurskunst
ist und weniger von Ideologie in dem
Moment wo ich einen klaren Weg für den
Fußgänger für den Autofahrer für den
Radfahrer hat kommen die sich
gegenseitig weniger in die Quere ich
habe weniger Unfalltote und es sorgt für
weniger Stress insofern kann ich nur
sagen ich verstehe die Debatten die hier
sehr emotional und mit Ideologie und
kulturkampfbegriffen geführt werden
nicht weil wenn ich mir z.B die
Holländer angucke die seit über 20
Jahren von einer liberalen Partei
geführt werden da fährt jeder Mensch
Fahrrad geht jeder zu Fuß fährt jeder
Auto fährt jeder öffentlichen und das
wird als eine rationale Entscheidung
wahrgenommen die ich morgens treffe je
nachdem wie mein Verkehrsweg aussieht in
der Friedrichstraße in Berlin konnte man
sich nicht mehr aussuchen da durfte man
nur noch mit dem Fahrrad fahren bis das
Gericht kam und gesagt hat jetzt dürfen
wieder Autos fahren jetzt ist aber die
Nachbarstraße die Parallelstraße in
Berlin dann zur Fahrradstraße gemacht
worden also hier wird das Auto nach und
nach raus gedrängt aus der Stadt ja also
Berlin ist ja ein fails Date also nicht
nur da sondern die können ja nicht mal
Wahlen durchführen und ich finde das
Verkehrschaos was hier in Berlin in der
Innenstadt ist eine Katastrophe also wer
hier im Auto unterwegs ist dem beneide
ich nicht sondern das ist wirklich eine
Katastrophe wenn man jetzt so eine
zentrale Straße dicht machen will wie
die Friedrichstraße dann für das noch
mehr zum Chaos in der in Berlin Mitte
interessanteste Frau kapic wenn sie dann
diese Fahrradwege
einweihen wenn die eröffnet werden
sozusagen dann fährt die Berliner Grünen
Fraktionschefin dann doch mit dem Auto
vor und steigt für das Foto mal locker
aus Fahrrad um das war ein glücklich
oder ist das heuchlerisch nee im
Gegenteil sie hat es ja nicht versteckt
sie ist ja nicht drei Straßen weiter
umgestiegen er ist sie nicht sondern sie
ist direkt zu dem Termin mit dem Auto
gefahren weil sie es anders nicht
geschafft haben ich kenne ich kenne
Bettina Jara seit fast 20 Jahren und ich
kann Ihnen sagen man trifft sie egal wo
immer auf so einem finde ich nicht
besonders schönen Mountainbike und das
Haar fliegt weil sie einfach fanatische
Fahrradfahrerin ist sie hasst es an
ihrem Senatoren Job dass sie zu so
vielen Termin doch ab und zu mit dem
Auto muss aber wenn sie es muss
verheimlich weil es gehört das haben wir
vorhin das hat der Knie habe ich gesagt
es gehört einfach zur Lebensrealität
dazu das ist manchmal ähm so ist dass
man das Auto braucht und das gilt gerade
mal für Beschäftigte Minister aber das
ist genau der Punkt ob man ob man das
nicht ausblendet in der Politik wird
wenn man mit dem Auto vorfährt um dann
aufs Fahrrad umzusteigen der Koch ganz
viele in Deutschland sind eben einfach
aufs Auto angewiesen in so vielen
zunächst einmal wir haben noch Einigkeit
ist doch toll wenn mein Fahrradwege
haben das eine gute Sache zu nutzen ist
eine wunderbare Ergänzung du sprichst
nichts dagegen alles funktioniert
eben ja gehört dass ich gesagt habe in
Holland sei alles so prima und dort wäre
alles gut wenn sie nach Holland gehen
dann haben sie dort unglaublich viele
Tankstellen wo Sie heute schon CO2
neutralen Kraftstoff tanken können der
ist in ganz Europa gewünscht in
Deutschland ist er verboten es verboten
in Deutschland und das ist eine
skandalöse Entwicklung wenn sie in
Deutschland als Tankstellenbesitzer
sondern CO2 neutralen Kraftstoff
anbieten bekommen sie Post müssen Sie
rechts können wir durchkämpfen in
Holland haben Sie warum ist das verboten
politischer will der ist also von wem ja
Ja
Nein sagen
dann stehen sie ganz leicht den
Verkehrshaus das was er gerade
dargestellt hat ist ja ein Produkt der
Vorgängerregierung ja also
und dass man die beiden Mischung aber
wann ist das Datum das müssen wir jetzt
in dieser Sendung erklären wann ist das
Datum wo sie aufhören ist alles auf die
Vorgänger noch kannst du tun wie lange
ja noch kann ich es tun aktuell denn das
Problem ist ja tatsächlich dass die
Beimischungen von diese dass das im Kern
hartriegeltiert ist und ist eigentlich
notwendig wäre dass man Biokraftstoffe
stärkt okay also komischen vorne ist
Ihre Kamera sie können jetzt im Sinne
ihres Verkehrsministers denn die FDP
Stellen versprechen wenn Sie diese
Auffassung sind das zu ändern wenn die
FDP bei der nächsten Bundestagswahl die
absolute Mehrheit hat dann werden sie
brauchen noch vier Jahre dann sie
stellen den Verkehrsminister was bringt
dann FDP
verlassen Verkehrsmeister sondern das
ist natürlich auch der Frage der
Umweltministerin beispielsweise die
Grünen stellen ja das ist nicht nur eine
Frage des ftp-ministers und Sie können
mir glauben hat sie FDP nicht gegeben
dann wäre der Verbrennermotor ab 2035
tot in Deutschland
zu der politischen Debatte ein Herr Koch
machten Vorschlag der seiner Meinung
nach technisch technologisch sinnvoll
ist der Schäffler der Wirtschaftsexperte
der FDP sitzt daneben und nickt und sagt
er gut wir stellen zwar den
Verkehrsminister aber ändern können wir
auch nicht
das habe ich nicht gesagt ihr habt
gesagt natürlich haben wir was verändert
ja ich will es noch mal betonen auf
europäischer Ebene ist es möglich
künftig nach 2035 weiterhin
Verbrennungsmotoren vorzuhalten und die
auch mit synthetischen Kraftstoffen
beispielsweise zu sie sind tatsächlich
ein Quantensprung weil das viele
Tausende von Arbeitsplätzen in
Deutschland sichern wird also ich finde
das immer jetzt mal so aus dem Bauch
raus gesehen dass das ist alles irgendwo
nicht nicht schlüssig also man hat immer
irgendwo das Gefühl da ist so eine
unsichtbare Mehrheit im Raum die wünscht
da irgendwas wir müssen voranmarschieren
Deutschland geht vorne weg dann gucke
ich mal ja eigentlich hat uns niemand
dazu auch erkoren wir selber wir kommen
wieder auf die wir müssen das jetzt
machen wir stellen zwar fest dass
E-Mobilität alleine nicht funktioniert
reiten aber weiter diesen Weg gehen
immer weiter lassen Sie mich doch auch
mal ein bisschen
das sind doch die falschen Arbeitsplätze
dafür vielleicht also auf jeden Fall
sind diese ganzen diese ganzen können
nicht vernünftig entsorgt werden die
werden hergestellt
das ist richtig richtig
Fahrzeuge ja und wenn es so viele wären
wenn so viele wären wie sie gerne hätten
dann können wir jetzt hier gar nicht
auftauchen weil wir nicht überall
ausgehen soll
auf der Straße
stimmt
nicht wissen erzählt aber nicht wir
sitzen natürlich wir haben gerade mal
eine Million man kann mit dem e-batterie
1000 km fahren
Recht die alte Bundesregierung hat
festgelegt dass wir mindestens 15
Millionen bis 2035 brauchen um die
Klimaziele einzuhalten das ist das eine
wir brauchen ganze Strom herkommen
wir wollen diese moderne Industrie haben
nein die waren denn die Elektromobilität
Arbeitsplätze waren dann gerade zu siehe
Tesla wenn wir Interessantes geblende
spielen dann kommen die 6000
Arbeitsplätze in Brasilien
in Deutschland gemacht
jetzt aber noch mal die waren eben auf
der Straße komplett
gar nicht neu hinzugefügt jetzt aber
noch mal kurz zur Straße weil wir gehen
ja wir wollen ja nicht nur über
Kraftstoffe reden das Auto in Berlin
nehmen wir mal das schöne Beispiel
Berlin hat tatsächlich 22% der Wege es
macht tatsächlich 40 % der
Verkehrsleistung es braucht aber 80% der
Fläche ja das heißt wir müssen darüber
nachdenken wie die flächengerechtigkeit
stattfinden wie kriegen wir mehr Band
aber das ist aber ein anderen Städten
auch so eine andere europäische Städte
haben die meisten Menschen in
Deutschland wohnen auf dem Land ja Nein
und nicht mit einem so tollen
öffentlichen Verkehrsnetz wie hier in
Berlin der Knie was ist also das
Zukunftsmodell für die Altenpflegerin
die auf dem Land wohnt die ständig mit
ihrem kleinen eine Frau Betrieb über
Land fahren muss die ihre Patienten ist
versorgen muss es bleibt es bleibt auf
dem ländlichen Raum natürlich das Auto
das Auto wird aber in Sekundenschnelle
wird es natürlich zu einem öffentlichen
Verkehrsmittel weil die die Frau und
auch viele andere können müssen nicht
alleine durch die Gegend fahren sondern
man kann ratzfatz auf digitalen
Plattform wunderbar ich selber ich ganz
allein selber ob ich Menschen mitfahren
lassen kann oder nicht das heißt wenn
wir auch am ländlichen Raum die Autos
dieser Zeit liegt das einzige
Verkehrsmittel davon
machen muss es nicht machen aber es gibt
ja viele Leute die sehr gerne andere
Leute mitnehmen wir haben unglaublich
viele drei Möglichkeiten auch
machen weil weil meine meine
Alltagserfahrung spricht dagegen dass
das funktionieren kann
das ist jetzt sicherlich eine extremes
Beispiel aber die Altenpflegerin sagen
sie die über Land fährt die kann
Carsharing machen
die Macht kleiner Unterschied die wird
immer mit ihrem Auto fahren kann
in diesem Bereich aber das ist natürlich
wirklichkeitsfremd das wird in meiner
Region in dieser Form nicht geben an den
Menschen morgen individuell 30 40
Kilometer zur Arbeit fahren müssen
unterschiedliche Zeitpunkte haben wann
Sie genau wann Sie Feierabend hast das
größte Problem das Experiment machen den
nächsten Jahren das wird nicht
funktionieren das wirklichkeitsfremd das
mag in Berlin funktionieren meine in
Berlin gibt es mobilitätsmodelle die nur
da funktionieren naja Großstadt aber
viele Menschen wohnen eben nicht in der
Großstadt sondern leben auf dem Land und
da funktioniert das eben nicht und wenn
es funktionieren würde sehen sehr teuer
ja wenn Sie eine Elektrofahrzeug kaufen
dann ist es eben auch teurer als
normales Fahrzeug
[Musik]